[Music]
americans held hostage abandoned behind
enemy lines day 27
day 27 americans held hostage behind
enemy lines we have a lot of news to
bring on that front tonight now tonight
let's start with your freedom is under
assault doctor joe biden not sure what
medical school he went to won't take no
for an answer now it's your it's your
body it's his choice with an
unconstitutional illegal unethical
federal vaccine mandate that by the way
he said he would never support one that
jen saki told us that it is not the role
the federal government to do one that
nancy pelosi said they don't have the
authority to do it and kamala harris was
the one that said it's your body you get
to make the choice and to make matters
worse this has nothing to do with your
health or safety instead this is a cold
it is a calculated it is a political
ploy biden's presidency has been a
complete disaster in every single way
think of one thing can you name one
thing that he's done that you could
point to that you think is a success he
abandoned americans behind enemy lines
can't even tell us how many he abandoned
daryl isis says around 500 13 american
heroes are now dead because of joe's
afghan disaster when he had control of
kabul he could have gotten every
american out safely every afghan ally
out safely all our equipment out safely
his poll numbers are in the basement
he's desperate to galvanize support
around a shared common enemy that enemy
is some americans that don't buy into
his
one size fits all unscientific medicine
think about this one one size fits all
no medical exemptions let's start there
how is that following
science it's not especially those who
refuse to follow his vaccine rules and
mandates including republican governors
by the way who won't act like many
dictators who actually believe strongly
in a principle that joe gives lip
service to and it's called liberty and
freedom and choice joe says it's not
about freedom it's not about choice it
is about freedom it is about your choice
it is about your unique medical history
and your current medical condition and
what your doctor thinks not a phony
doctor or tv guys that think the doctor
or play doctor on tv
americans that value their medical
privacy americans that value
doctor-patient confidentiality and
anyone else who believes in personal
freedom joe biden's help heartfelt unity
pledge oh that lasted all but seven
months now it's us versus them and dr
joe's patience is wearing thin he wants
to lecture you and scold you for not
listening
restore the soul and secure the future
of america
requires so much more than words
it requires the most elusive of all
things in a democracy
unity this is not about freedom or
personal choice
it's about protecting yourself my whole
soul is in this
bringing america together
uniting our people my message to
unvaccinated americans is this
what more is there to wait for
what more do you need to see with unity
we can do great things important things
we've been patient
but our patience is wearing thin this is
our historic moment
of crisis and challenge
and unity
is the path forward
and your refusal has cost all of us
so please do the right thing
now clearly joe's unity pledge was a lie
now half the country is what enemy
number one because they don't want to
follow dr joe
uh in fact democrats say
nicer things about illegal immigrants
and even the taliban some of them than
the 80 million unvaccinated americans i
guess it's open season on them do you
know anything about their medical
condition their medical history you know
anything about what their doctors are
advising them according to the biden
administration 20 years after 9 11 the
taliban is professional and they are
business-like but if you're unvaccinated
and you're an american unvaccinated
you're ignorant you're selfish and he's
his patience is running out take a look
time to start prioritizing icu beds uh
for people who are vaccinated they're
saying the taliban is business-like and
professional their interior minister has
an fbi wanted poster he's got a 10
million dollar bounty on his head in
order to get those people out we had to
work with some members of the taliban to
press them uh and to work uh in a
business-like manner to get them out i
just think if you don't want to play by
any of those rules and then all of a
sudden you end up in the hospital i feel
bad that you
but maybe you shouldn't go and take up
the resources from someone else
immigrants coming to our country with
newcomers coming with their hopes and
dreams and aspirations
with their optimism and determination to
make the future better for their
families
well those are american traits
so according to the left crossing our
borders illegally breaking our laws
that's heroic no vaccine mandates for
illegal aliens no mandatory tasks just
chose overcrowded cages in the middle of
a pandemic with a very high rate of pose
covered positivity including those not
tested and then by the way then you get
to pick the state of your choice you'll
be dispersed all over the country not
even getting a cova test joe's following
the science really and you want to
lecture
americans and scold americans and tell
them how bad they are and how they
should be hated and give license to
attacks on people that have different
views or medical conditions you might
not even know about but you better get
the vaccine or dr joe biden is going to
unleash the full force of the federal
government against you and your loved
ones and your employer and you will be
canceled in society together you'll be
shut out of everything illegal aliens by
the way i see that male orcas won't use
that term anymore starting today
apparently or yesterday they uh they get
no mandates and free trips to the state
right they get free trips no mandates
get to go to the state of their choice
and they get free health care and free
education you pay for that all while
totally exempt from this mandate take a
look
united states but it's a requirement for
people at a business with more than 100
people it's not a requirement for
migrants of the southern border why
that's correct go ahead
the rules don't apply to illegal
immigrants or members of congress or
their staffers it wasn't even going to
apply to postal workers until public
pressure forced the administration to
reverse course late today but it does
apply to millions of law-abiding
americans
it doesn't matter if you have a rare
pre-existing condition and your doctor
thinks taking the vaccine is very risky
and not the right choice for you it
doesn't matter if you had coven and you
have t-cell immunity from a prior
infection cleveland clinic says the
science is pretty clear on that so far
it doesn't matter if you prefer to keep
your medical decisions private the frail
the weak the mentally incompetent
impaired president dr joe knows best and
of course the mandate is deeply
unconstitutional on top of all of this
at least 10 governors are now planning
legal action including governor known
governor abbott governor desantis and
shadow president chief of staff ron
claim he's now apparently congratulating
himself calling the new mandate the
ultimate workaround for a federal
vaccine requirement but anyone with a
functioning brain knows that the mandate
is in serious legal jeopardy even fake
news cnn attorneys recognize this and
that's why a few months ago several top
democrats promised there would be no
federal vaccine mandate because it's not
the role of the federal government take
a look how things change
no i don't think it should be mandatory
i wouldn't demand to be mandatory
perhaps the federal government should
step in and issue mandates and if not
are you putting the needs of
unvaccinated people ahead of the needs
of vaccinated people well i think the
question here one that's not the role of
the federal government
that is the role that institutions
private sector entities
and others may take we cannot require
someone to be vaccinated
that's just not what we can do i am all
for um more vaccination um but uh you
know i i have nothing further to say on
that except that we're looking into
those policies and and quite honestly as
people are doing that locally um those
are those are individual local decisions
as well i don't think you'll ever see a
mandating of the vaccine particularly
for the general public
oh okay
uh another big change of the goal pulse
moves like every day why would anyone
have any faith want to know where
vaccine hesitancy comes from the people
that changed their mind every five
seconds and the people that were wrong
in every prediction they ever made they
keep changing everything every single
day no mass one mass two mass vaxxer
masks now it's facts and mask now it's
vax mask and add a booster to it
apparently they were all lying and now
biden is in a desperate attempt at a
political scapegoat and unvaccinated
americans fit the bill same guy that
left open borders and no testing of
illegal immigrants with a high rate of
covert positivity and then dumped in
joe's cages that's right
a petri dish if you will and dr joe just
can't understand why anyone would be
vaccine hesitant why on earth would
anyone not trust the experts you know
the ones that were wrong about the
origins of covid uh and some actually
really lied we now know the
transmissibility of covert the use of
ventilators the vaccine timeline the
threshold for herd immunity the ones who
promised two weeks to slow the spread
the ones who told us not to wear masks
and one mask then two masks and mass
outdoors and no mass outdoors facts to
mass vax mast and
and and now boostered
and on and on can you keep up even joe
and kamala they expressed a hesitancy
over the vaccine maybe they forgot
let's just say there's a vaccine that is
approved and even distributed before the
election
would you get it well i think that's
going to be an issue for all of us um
i will say that i would not trust donald
trump getting vaccinated is the single
best defense against 19 and its variance
it's the simple best defense i trust
scientists but i don't trust donald
trump
at this moment the american people can't
either i'm going to continue to do
everything i can to encourage the
unvaccinated to get vaccinated
that includes addressing hesitancy and
misinformation head on
actually unlike
unlike joe and kamala i actually believe
in the science i believe in the science
of vaccination under trump and i believe
in them now and as i said many times i'm
not a doctor i can't tell you what to do
i don't know anything about your medical
history i don't know anything about your
current medical condition but you better
take this seriously people die i know
people that ended up on ventilators some
that barely survived and some that died
i am a radio and television host that's
right i'm a member of the mob in the
media except we're the good side of the
mob
and we also are members of the press i'm
not a medical doctor i didn't go to
medical school now we will do our best
to keep you informed and bring on
experts with all different points of
view but only you know your unique
medical history and current condition
and only you in consultation with your
doctors should make that informed
important decision about a vaccine not
any television host and frankly not any
any swamp member in dc
not any of the wannabe doctors on fake
news cnn or msdnc
certainly not dr joe biden i'd like to
know what medical school he went to or
anybody in the federal government
without a medical license you have a
personal responsibility to protect
yourself your family and others and how
you do that is your business not mine
but you do have that responsibility not
dr joe's either individual freedom
liberty is a precious right in this
country once you lose it it will be gone
forever hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else